oh hey you know what's in here no but I
can read it these are the brand new of
throat boy pillows this is the 10th
anniversary throw boys in making pillows
for 10 years I've known Roberto for a
really really long time I remember I
thought side of his suitcase that he had
he was giving pills away on the street
in Austin Texas it's off my Southwest
and I said I can fit in that suitcase
thank us what I did you fit in this
suitcase I bet this is okay sounds like
a very Justine thing to do I remember
that subscribe pillow from like forever
many places ago we used to live you guys
remember the red subscribe below the
yellow all of the pillows but today
we're unboxing the brand new ones that
he has there is a Kickstarter for a few
more days
he met his Kickstarter goal within like
hours which is incredible you know this
isn't my first I thought in my original
one is still at home with my parents
house and it is it's at home so I
clearly don't have it here I don't think
it works either they don't like Savi ago
this one does though
look at that it made tunes on there
there's a lot of Adele hey first iPod
Playa del which is maybe in the next
update I wonder when they stopped
supporting this and I really sure
there's more things in here there's more
things okay first iPod show the bellows
is squishy oh it's nice this one oh yeah
oh man just like how this has like the
Apple logo am I gonna hang low though
next up let's rise it's gonna be the
1984 Mac
oh it is not the 1984 Matt this is the
1977 Mack that's a long time ago hot
wait when 1977 you weren't here I wasn't
here I wasn't here we weren't here our
parents were young you leave your little
Wow we that's crazy okay
oh maybe the next MacBook keyboard will
sound like this
oh jokes she's got him Jenny as Eric was
here I always thought Justine was here I
swear to you because I have a video
where I even say what I was typing and
that was what I do it isn't a nice
silent wow these are so cool put your
hat on it resting this seat fool I'm so
tired
I miss the average of the Mac sandwich
okay next what do we have what do we
have
oh there's three more oh I'll get that
this is the original iPhone honey
okasada
where's my original iPhone I never have
that because I was too young to have a
phone no I don't think I talk to you hey
Siri when did the original iPhone come
out seven visit to apple.com show 8007
no I had a phone I was like 17
Virgil iPhone let's make it the same
size wait I should move it this way here
we go okay perspective you know
hey Siri yes how can I help you
next fill up with home kids what if Siri
is saying hey Siri why isn't she not
trimming the other side crazy and the
answer to that the crazy thing is I sort
of have all of this stuff in my house
right now I just did an unboxing of the
Apple to see which is not quite this one
the Apple to see came out around 1984
around the same time as this little guy
this is the original original thing this
is that 1984 baby see my purse I wasn't
here I wasn't here and it wasn't easy
yeah as old as your mom mom dad or
someone I'm gonna block you I'm just yes
we also my grandmother she had the she
had a green called we had blue right I
had the the g4 it was a tower we had the
eMac I think it was eMac do you remember
that it was the white yes I do yeah and
then we had also the iMac what are the
ones with a swivel screen or not that
design was incredible swivel screen it's
kind of crazy just to be sitting here in
looking at some of the most incredible
products that Apple has really ever
created I mean each one of these kind of
defines the generation of Apple of where
things sort of like took an incredible
turn I mean this is like the first
graphical user interface we've got our
first iPhone which basically changed the
way that we use our phones
yeah like smart phones mobile phones the
iPod this completely revolutionized
music the way that we listen to it the
way that we find the way I mean if you
had to but if you had to buy individual
songs that got expensive well that well
they just now recently know you can't
really purchase music on Apple so that
also is another thing that has changed
now you can only stream it this
so changed everything because at this
point this is where everything sort of
pivoted for Apple they sort of like
where I'm trying to think of a song oh
it's upside down
hello do you remember not long ago no
the original was the marimba oh the
phone the marimba the marimba ring we
have so many Google's are just marimba
because she didn't think that it was
like basically the same things was out
of the phone when did we fight about
this this is a long time ago the marimba
and I think the marimba is wooden I
think that was the difference should we
look it up again because now I don't
remember and what's a marimba the
marimba is a percussion instrument
consisting of a set of wooden bars
traffic now it's called knots to produce
musical tones I used to have the rick
ross grunt you did as my alert for like
four years
weird no Matt exits like I'm putting it
back Rick Ross grunting I'm coming back
for you I am shipped to my cord gives me
such a panic feeling we are something
about talking with all that just makes
me want to just puke it's playing it
it's vomit inducing that is terrible and
you've got rick ross not this bad Oh
almost beautiful nanny looked at the
doorbell
why is that not my ringtone that's super
spooky okay we need to end this video we
do we got to go home there's a silo
phone ana marimba I don't hate you with
no you know I don't like pillow fight
thank you so much for watching a huge
thank you and congratulations to Roberto
at throw boy you guys have seen these
pillows even if you didn't know what
they were I love that he has created
such an iconic thing for our generation
I mean it's kind of crazy to think
because everybody has them like every
youtuber has one of these pillows or has
seen them or is heard of them and you
guys haven't seen them or heard of them
and you didn't even know it until now
unless you didn't know it but it leave
the description if you guys might check
out the cake started it's only a few
more days left I backed it the first day
because I was like yes sir so saw its
really psyched
I'm so excited somebody in my office and
stuff too so this is gonna look so good
idea I also have a 1984 Mac but I
haven't unboxed it yet I should have run
out the to see but it's it's in the box
I don't open it can it see you later see
yourself out I'm John I'll see you guys
later
keep thinking about again you're amazing
and thank you and congrats and I'll see
you guys in my next video see you later
see you later but my eyes are so cool I
had to hurt my thumb I didn't actually
know that's the wrong chord it's the
wrong chord but we can do a double knot
jumps same very well but I'm going this
way
[Music]